gang the state trashy tour is coming to
a city near you stand up comedy plus
we've played the Leo IG with the crowd
shows are selling out and you can get
your tickets at rugarbage.com see you
there
[Music]
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage it's that little show
we sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find out they're going to be
classy just a big old piece of trash I'm
your host Dave trolley coming at you on
a beautiful day we're out back here with
hoodies in the new edition little news
on her she was the big winner at bingo
last night great gonna be in the
newspaper awesome not for Bingo though
DWI my ghost is coming at you from
across the table got a head like a
chickpea but we love them give it up for
KJ Kevin James Ryan thanks a lot higher
happy to be here thanks for tuning in as
always please make sure you rate me make
sure you rape reviews you should have
been [__] on his family before make
sure you rate if you subscribe on iTunes
full video available on YouTube as you
know those numbers are
cooking then obviously the greatest
website of one one of the two greatest
websites of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage you go
over there and you get get a bajillion
hours of content I'm talking multiple
Wildwood videos got the boat video you
got the Charleston video you got all I
mean cribs vacation road tour Vlogs hard
feelings
bonus episodes every week check it the
frick out get a network over there it is
and then also the second greatest
website of all time www.ru garbage.com
pics go over there you get all the live
show tickets you need to the stay trashy
tour which I gotta be honest with you
are selling the frick out yes so go get
those tickets before they're sold out
and you're stuck out in the cold we love
you gang having a nice quick shout out
to our producer short and there I forget
when I need them sometimes they don't
really bit me in the ass on that 30. he
is a uh he's a kick flipping stand-up
comedian from the backwoods of North
Carolina by the way is Chicago Illinois
give it up for Toby McMullen everybody
what up boys so is that the is the hair
supposed to be like a helmetic it's high
today is it woofing it's baby it looks
strong looks like [__] Tony Hawk's
gonna drop in on that thing
looks like it looks like the wave in The
Perfect Storm
flips the boat
ah man going down with the ship that's
up there yeah it's a high it's high
today it doesn't look bad it's just
getting a little longer it looks good
you don't say it's getting a little
longer and I've been blow drying it I've
been getting it completely dry combing
it back and then just using a little bit
of crew forming cream in it so that's
kind of what it is I'm gonna get a
little trimmed up it's great good trim
get my eyebrows done get the ears
cleaned up hey not doing the nose
anymore I had a really bad infection
when I had my nose hair pulled it's no
good this has been gross hour with age
Foley everybody ingrown hairs and
infections with you two minutes in
nothing's gonna break my mood today I
don't know how much you make fun of me
it's [__] the fall and it feels good
very nice out there crisp in the air a
season of smells if I can say that right
here Amanda smells dude don't get that
don't sell yourself short people I love
the way it smells in the cities you know
what I mean when you get that you know
it's great Chris day you get that
hamburger smell
like it's like a restaurants nearby okay
and it smells like burgers
I don't get that how about pizza you get
it you gotta you get like that onion
sauce smell I don't equate that the
weather ah yeah I don't know it moves
through the air better when it's nice
out when there's a little bit of a light
Breeze and the humidity's low and the
barometric pressure plus it saves you
some steps because you start floating
towards me a cartoon like a [__] moth
to a light
is Christ
I feel like a good hamburger
um speaking of uh so all right I got
something I want to get into this is a
little hard feelings-esque okay because
I had hard feelings with the gentleman
uh in front of me in line at a store but
it does bring up an etiquette thing
which we we tend to talk about a lot on
these shows okay I gotta operate out
there in the world for a couple of bozos
sure uh I was at a
um
I want to say not a frozen yogurt like
an ice cream place a little more of a
higher end ice cream place yeah my wife
likes it so we were there I'm not I'm
not a sweets man I've said this a bunch
guys have a dinner roll
you got any ultrasounds back there it's
more of a gelato spot that's the word
I'm looking for a gelato which what is
the difference I know I know custard
there's egg in it which doesn't get
enough love Frozen Custard really's
gotten Bamboozled okay you don't do core
Brothers down the shore on the board
another big ice cream guy when it does
I'm I'm a Philly man through and through
so Rita's Water Ice all day every day
shout out to the chocolate the vanilla
the root beer man you know a root beer
water rice with a soft pretzy so under
[__] me in yeah it's all right also
shout out to bassett's ice cream
bastards ice cream Philadelphia original
the best vanilla in the world
um what is gelato do you know you're a
man of the world I do know the
difference between gelato and ice cream
is ice cream is made with cream and
gelato is made with milk
really yep just ruined my day I thought
it'd be more cream it's creamier why is
that so upsetting bummer I thought
there'd be a little more something in
there extra sugar or something yeah
they're skimming the [__] skimming
the ice cream these [__] guys
[__] yeah I don't know that's it gelato
to me is more fancy that's that's a
European thing gelato it's like ten
dollars more I don't even like going
into the store [__] call me bastards
I was like a Mussolini let me get a
chocolate
I was slightly off [__] grease balls
keep your eyes off my wife will keep my
wallet in my hand at all times
yeah trust them as far as I can throw
them uh it uses cream and milk but less
cream and more milk than ice cream
really yes huh
creamier and like uh flavorful than ice
cream I think sure it's awesome gelatos
great sure
um so you're in there we're in there
nice joint
um
we're in there and uh we go in and
they're known it is a little hoity-toity
it ain't like a chocolate vanilla
[__] John it's not it's not that it's
not the basics with like hey we got a
mint chocolate chip and a rocky road
honey and Rose pepper honey and Rose
hibiscus and this [__] fig and olive
oil very and it's just not my cup of tea
the bird loves it did you get something
no I don't you don't I have I've had it
she goes a lot I don't like it it's kind
of her guilty pleasure okay
um so we're in there there's Maybe
there's a couple one or two people in
front of us right you know and then like
one group's together it's called two
three people okay then a younger couple
mid 20s maybe 30 guy in a gal don't know
how long they've been dating early
dating Vibes it seems okay it wasn't
like
they weren't super lovey-dovey and they
weren't to the point where like they
were seeing it was still like engaged
they're like yeah I got you yeah not
just like oh we're doing a little
schmoopy a little bit but like she
wasn't super into it into it either way
that was just my thing I don't know that
doesn't have anything to do I mean wipe
it off do it later for sure maybe they
weren't together at all
so then uh me and my wife I'm not
ordering she's ordering and then uh I
think like one or two other people
behind a pretty busy not busy but you
know a nice flow of customers got it
as the couple the the couple in front of
us is getting up to go up
he goes Hey listen uh
uh which I do respect you is we're gonna
get some samples he turns around to you
and says this if you guys want to go in
front of us
nah it's fine I'm my head like all right
let's gonna be 40 seconds you know what
I mean like it's fine with no rush I'm
hanging
were you gonna get samples maybe what
maybe the bird was gonna try one if
they're big on the samples they got the
things there and because they changed
the flavor so frequently and they are so
unique it's like he's not I get that
he's not
asking for vanilla or whatever like let
me taste the vanilla well you're gonna
get a sample I wasn't getting a sample
you're not gonna touch nothing no I was
in a gelato place your wife's getting
something you're not gonna get a little
cup I already had my dessert which was
heaters
but this bothers me a little more than
anything else you're about to tell me
yeah because you don't like me but what
is it you don't get nothing I don't like
ice cream that's not my it's what
you're there you because then she gets
to have you well bite of yours it's not
all about you Kevin what what is it what
now listen I I would rather spend
those calories having beers I'd rather
have a cocktail after dinner did you get
the number of the kid in front of you
maybe have him here in here I hang out
with him sure he'll be kidding me
[__] bother him all day here's a
sample at least try something that's
even trashier to get a sample and not
eat it I've had it I just don't eat ice
cream every [__] three days okay
that's normal
it could have been a nice little treat
you know what the trait was [__]
beers and I bet you and heaters after
the the ice cream I bet you for her it's
a nice treat if you get it too you can
try hers she can try yours okay uh but
go ahead no because now you're not on my
ear now I'm on your side you're not yes
I am the enemy you already invited the
guy I don't like to come to the gym you
don't like him well how what is it what
happened what is the acceptable amount
of flavor testings I mean I don't know
at a place like that listen
where we come from there but there's
there's people behind you and I will
give you that he did offer but there's
at least when we started
another one or two people behind there's
a line where we come from
no eye contact and give me whatever's
cheapest one or two you know I mean what
are you doing
one or two I feel like three max three
max three max three max that's pretty
good because it's not like I mean when
you you have an idea of what you want
kind of gonna you gotta be in the world
you gotta what are you in the mood for
you got to be between two or three I'll
give you three something vanilla eat
chocolatey something fruity something
you know you have
I don't know but people are [__]
seven the number was seven each no
together oh no he had seven I think she
had one I was not concentrating on her
at all was he going he going around with
the questions
well what's that he would do one at a
time I don't think so oh you don't think
next one first of all they're going to
go then he was going maybe maybe that
well like he was put in another pile man
let's table that and come back to it
what do you think I had about five ipas
in me so I was a little anger who's this
guy Lenny Briscoe what the [__] are you
doing man I know that's crazy I'll give
you Seven's a lot Seven's a lot three is
a lot seven is a lot to do to the
[__] guy behind the counter no kid no
Kevin the guy no care for the guys you
guys mention those poor sea turtles
throwing all these tiny spoons in the
ocean I know they are a nice little Coke
spoon
I've seen in movies you ever see a
Snapper on coke
um
the way I look at that and I'm a fat pig
and but there's a courtesy involved it's
well established that I'm the kind of
guy that I mean I'll take anything
really
you know what I mean sure so like I
could just go in there blind what do you
like unless you're like I hate rhubarb
don't give me the ruble which I do yeah
I don't think a lot of people add a lot
to it my mom brought a cherry rhubarb
pie Home One Time by mistake he really
crucified her
it was really just bad I don't even know
what rhubarb is it's rude to be in that
[__] mean dear mom when she tries to
get you the hell is this Patty
how many times I gotta tell you I don't
like rhubarb start shaking her keys you
got somewhere to go and get me a blue
you better hurry up they close in 15
minutes I'll call and tell them that
[__] leave the light on for you
otherwise I go into school tomorrow with
a black eye
Seven's a lot seven is too many I would
say it's three yeah threes threes
because at a certain number it feels
like you're trying what does [__]
get I remember no I was so I was seeing
blind it was red because I was seeing
Ray how long are we talking how long did
this take five minutes no minutes
minutes but there's uh did give you the
out though but then there were still
people behind them like behind me
like there's a constant flow of people
coming in yeah and you're so you're
jamming them up and you're also jamming
the guy the guy's In The Weeds now he's
got a line that's [__] what's the guy
officially in the weeds he was on the
border of the weeds hmm plus seven free
samples I ain't [__] with his bottom
line I know that's enough which Hey
listen if it was a big Corporation
Costco whatever ransacked a joint take
[__] you know take costume put up my
fake mustache on go get more and more
and more they want they gotta give those
out
seven that's like a small he already got
he's already got a free cup that is you
see what I'm saying yeah that's trashy
behavior in my book yeah I do respect
the Patty was not big on the try in it
when we were kids we were not allowed we
got one maybe maybe and it had to be
like [__] it had to be new or
something
that'd be something you ain't never
heard of before
had to be something off the wall yeah we
weren't trying the [__] strawberry
you know I I yeah no it had to be
[__] Dippin Dots maybe you could
trust something like that never had them
if they were getting it's one it's
different if they're giving out samples
if they got a tray of samples you can
ransack that ransack it all you want
but the guy's got to take the lid off
[__] scoop in hand it all right and
then he does the walls of like I don't
think so for a [__] scoop ice cream
come on dude gelato whatever
that's that's up there with someone who
tries the wine and then sends it back to
me like who's doing that but is that I
don't know that's not I don't live in
that way we've talked about this
that yeah that doesn't work you can't do
that that that's why that's all [__]
that's why when they try to do that when
I'm at dinner the bird gets mad at me
because I'm like first of all if we
order the wine after we order okay
you're you got you got a big thing with
this though you do we got drinks so just
open the wine and leave it on the table
that's all you got to do I'll we'll I'll
pour it when we're ready to have dinner
you don't gotta feel pretty tense
talking about it you're talking to him
like he's the goddamn help
[__] don't touch my bottle of wine
it's not that it's I don't want you're
not using me as the spectacle all right
I'm not the hood of the car at the
[__] State Fair because we were at
this place one time and it was like a
cheap bottle of wine and they try to do
the [__] decanter everyone's looking
at us I'm like you don't got to do that
but the only way you can send the wine
back is if it's corked and if it's
corked everyone's gonna know because the
Cork's gonna be [__] up the Wine's
gonna taste like [__] it's gonna look
weird you can't just say oh no no I
don't like this and then they have a
bottle of wine that they only sell by
the bottle not by the glass
I understand etiquette wise but can you
say no I don't want it if it's not cool
I don't think so
I mean then what's the point you're
gonna get a lot of pushback right that's
what I'm assuming and no one knows
anything about wine to be like well the
notes of this and that sure I'm just
saying let's live in that world can't
just say I don't like it let's live in
that world with this person who's
ordering this bottle of wine has no
quality the same [__] this [__]
punk kid probably this [__] punk kid
who's gonna strike out on this date is
there uh is there did she get any
samples you asked me I think well
nothing to the standard if any if if any
standard one two what a [__] I like
the kid
saying go ahead ahead of it and I
thought I was like oh no buddy take your
time I was more offended for the guy
working than me I got nowhere to go sure
I'm drunk I got a pack of heaters I'm
going you're putting this you're making
this guy jump through hoops yeah so you
can look like a [__] Aficionado in
front of your [__] also that makes
you look like a bozo run away you're in
here with if you're trying to because
girl you found at the Greyhound station
try to impress her with some gelato
[__] piece of [__] yeah I I to me
it's more like one you're embarrassing
yourself in front of what seemed to be
an early relationship yeah you go yeah
I'll tell you how I'll taste one oh I'll
taste what you're tasting I'll take the
job I'd love to get a lady's opinion on
that is that something that would bother
a lady of like if you were on if you
were out with somebody I'm sure that's a
big make sure that you went to a gelato
place and they got seven samples which
this is a big thing you know what I mean
this has been going on I mean people
abusing the samples sure you know which
like I said if there's a treasure
samples abuse it all day long rip these
corporate scumbags off for sure do that
but this poor guy shucking [__]
gelato yeah you ever scoop ice cream
no I have but not in not in front of the
scene behind the scene at like
Bareburger we had to make shakes and
stuff it ain't easy no that's hard you
get those forearms dude it's hard and
when you have to do it under pressure in
front of [__] people especially when
they're being [__] pricks about it it
fits it ain't easy
what'd you find out about the wine
uh so can I send the next one back so
the what I found never I relax so this
is this is a pretty extensive art I took
a whole bottle of white wine in my head
in [__] Indy because I ordered the
wrong wine
yeah don't act like that's a punishment
what the [__] I had to chug a whole
bottle of wine and make an ass out of
myself
uh this says what you are not doing is
tasting the wine to see if it's just
right for you tonight yes the only
acceptable reason to reject wine is
faultiness full stop so if it takes
quirky or or it's it's gone bad yes
otherwise you just you have to say yes
I'm taking it you take the hit you go oh
that sucks thank you so much
A lot of people don't they try to be
[__] [__] about it that's why
and I'm not doing it to be a dick I I
don't want you to be nice about it I
don't want no I don't want you to you
and I to have to go through this [__]
charade okay
[__] poor herder glass if there's no
drinks pour her in a glass pour me a
glass I don't need to taste it I don't
know what the [__] I'm talking about I
know but and I got news for you neither
do you so not you specifically this is
all diesel directed Adobe this is also
that's such a funny sentence because
I've I've been with you at multiple
occasions at restaurants where you've
been looking at wine and said out loud I
know what I'm doing yeah oh yeah I mean
I know what I'm doing you try to throw
it in my face all the time I know what
I'm doing to a degree no no I do no I
worked in fine dining for [__] 15
years you worked at Bareburger you just
said you don't know that was at the end
of my career those are those are my
casual years I was here for tired
me
I have a general knowledge of wine
you ordered a red you ordered a white
wine thinking it was red that's
something I would do I make mistakes I
admit I admit okay and I [__] housed
it like a goddamn man I didn't go crying
in the [__] server working on it no
one said that no one said that but also
at the same time of like
that's that guy's job whether you like
this is awful it's got to be Poland
Spring
at the same time tasted wine shut up
that's that guy's job whether you're
entering into a social con you're the
only one going don't do this the
sommelier yeah that's their job and
you're going to a nicer restaurant and
you're ordering a bottle of wine where
someone's gonna come over and tell you
about the bottle of wine that's the rub
baby that's the those are the tricks I
also I don't believe in decantering
unless it's a certain amount of money
which I'm not [__] getting I know but
you buy a thousand dollars a thousand
dollar bottle of wine that's [__] 20
years old sure you want to get some air
and do it I know but that's also like
your girl you're I'm not saying you're
wrong I'm just saying you're the that's
that guy's job to go here and like this
is this is a service we provide for the
people that buy bottles of wine so you
can't get like your feathers ruffled
when they when they try to do their job
at the same time you know what I mean
but that argument could go back to the
[__] kid pool scooping the ice cream
that's part of his job and you got your
feathers ruffled
aha no that's yes that's not part of his
job part of his job is to give samples
yeah unfortunately that somalia's job is
to pour your one that's his job that is
his job but you see my argument
no it'd be one thing if you asked to
sample the wine
and that's seven times yeah which I
wouldn't do I don't think you can sample
like yeah
piggyback a [__] a couple
Boilermakers
oh what a cab Chaser you got three
fingers of Pinot huh no that is the his
main job this is an auxiliary thing to
the the courtesy that uh that the ice
cream scooper does yes I don't need to
be doing this what the ice cream scooper
would say that yeah but he does but he's
got him he's got [__]
man you gotta get his weed money you
know
seven I wish you knew what he got
yeah I don't know I was Furious I was
the perfect amount of drunk and uh
baffled by this yeah a little bit of a
[__] move Gang This is Helix
mattress baby let's talk about it I
jerked off on one last night at my house
and you were sleeping on the couch gag
we love Helix over here you don't gotta
go to a mattress store you go online now
you take the quiz you find out how you
sleep whether you sleep on your side
your back hot cold small big whatever
you got they got you covered over there
take the quiz takes two three minutes
find out what the optimal mattress is
for you and they send it right to your
door yeah uh if you don't get enough
sleep it can throw the whole week out of
whack dude you're trying to catch up
blah blah blah mental health breaks down
trust me a good night's sleep or hippies
in a mood turn it around I got the
Twilight mattress it's fantastic I got
about two or three of them I got I got
them in a new house I got the Cali king
let's go uh Helix knows there's no
better way to test a mattress than
actually get it and use it in your home
that's why they offer a hundred night
free tries that's nuts uh and a 10 to 15
year warranty to test things out whether
you're a side sleeper back sleeper run
hot or run cold Helix has something for
you baby Helix is offering 20 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
Ru garbage listeners gang go to Helix
sleep.com garbage that's Helix sleep.com
slash garbage this is their best offer
yet it won't last long with Helix better
sleep starts now do it Kippy like that
bespoke post oh baby shout out to the
box that keeps on giving yeah the box of
awesome is what we're talking about gang
you like doing cool guy stuff you like
having a cool guy gear Falls coming
around the corner nice pocket knife some
stuff for camping some stuff for the
bars some nice grooming stuff they got
you covered with that box awesome 90 of
everything that comes in your box of
awesome is from a small up and coming
brand each box is valued at seven around
seventy dollars but you pay a fraction
of that price getting started so is uh
easy peasy just take the quiz at
boxofosso.com your answers help them
pick the right box for you like we said
they send me everything I got knives I
got far stuff I'm making smoke cocktails
I got cool stuff for my car camp in the
bar whatever you need new boxes are
released every month and across a ton of
different categories so whether you're
in the bartending campaign box awesome
that's something you'll love it's
totally free to sign up you can skip a
month at any time get 20 off your first
monthly box when you sign up at box of
awesome.com enter the code garbage at
checkout that's box of awesome.com code
garbage for 20 off your first box of
balls.com
in that same vein uh-huh just a reverse
side of it uh you got any you got any
gelato on you I got it I go to the deli
counter uh at my at my local grocer on
Sunday to get a little berjuta to Parma
all right little Bijou okay thin slice
is how how we take it in the Foley
household
usually two thick sliced that's about
usually pretty thin Parma ham what
parmesan do people do it thin no I'm
saying it's always bacon that's what I'm
saying it's always thin yeah but you say
thin you still say thin okay I don't
know this kid you might know what the
[__] he's doing let me get let me get a
let me get an oinker though it's on
those epics but this guy comes up and
this is what he does you ready I'm just
gonna show you doesn't say hey whatever
just comes up
oh the tap on the table hang on you
ready I didn't know what he was doing
because I was in a good mood well that's
an example
and he goes
he's leaning in with the ear over the
counter
and I'm like [__] I thought he was
like looking at something
happen does that
and he goes you want something
oh oh wait he's on the other side of the
camera he's the guy he's the [__]
slicer I thought he was on your side
okay I thought he was a jerk-off
customer being like what do you want no
or what can I get no this guy came over
I would have said something that guy
came over and whoa yeah having a rough
day I guess sure been there yeah no hi
how you doing no hi how you doing what
can I get you I I just I was just so
taken aback I didn't want to be like
like let me get a because I didn't know
that I was getting the let me get seven
samples
let me try to Boar's Head let me try the
Deets and Watts a couple of Blazing
Buffalo no I don't want anything just
making a sandwich you got two slices of
bread no you know what I don't want
nothing
what's the profile on that American
cheese the yellow yeah it gives me that
real two
sure set me back a little bit now let me
ask you this ask us T-Bone have you ever
done the grocery store beverage sample
I'm talking about slugging a little Bevy
and then popping it back on the Shelf as
you're cruising now what are you
drinking warm soda oh you can pull from
the thing in the front but that stuff
because you're going up by that you're
flying by the tower you're you're flying
by all the staff grabbing a pet no one's
watching though as a cashier that's
[__] up do you do that not in years
but I have especially those like uh
lemon ginger Shooters I'll get myself a
little a little a little immunity boost
you stealing hippie I'm going to the
frozen food section it's freezing over
there
I don't want to catch a cold
never a big stealer one or two things as
young and dumb but never never I always
there I've said this before I have such
I would have so much shame getting
caught and then also like my parents of
being like you're stealing [__]
whatever I've told you but man two kids
in high school these two twins [__]
my senior year their junior year their
mom got popped in the grocery store
stealing lunch meat yeah
stuff they were jammed up though I had a
kid uh I knew a kid and I ridiculed them
but still yeah I mean hey you gotta do
your it builds character at that point
uh I had a kid stealing credit cards all
right uh he like worked somewhere and
people would call it like it was like a
smaller it wasn't like a hotline it was
like I'm making this up a local florist
or something and people like yeah put it
on my credit card and he would write
down the number then take it and just
put like 20 bucks of gas here you know
hey then he started being like hey give
me 50 bucks I'll fill up your tank if it
cost 80 bucks or you know started
skimming it's working but then all these
car charges like what the somebody was
just like oh they've all been
charged and somebody linked it together
to Jenny's Flowers
and then they they had on him on like
every [__] uh
uh gas station video that's like filling
people's things up I was like damn we
were like [__] 16 too all right it's
going for it I like it makes floors you
send flowers uh luckily my wife's not a
big flower gal not to her but to other
people what it's nice to send food
Michael Moore
who else am I sending flowers to who Who
besides my wife who would I be sending
flowers to I don't know I've sent
flowers in the last couple of months to
who uh my mom my cousin
couple people send flowers okay I sent
you some flowers yeah no nice you no
only a lady I was
dating working well I wouldn't call it
that you wanna Hammond
slice thick
beat me to it
it's good
um I would uh yeah no I I have a couple
times but never uh it's not her her cup
of tea yeah flowers are nice sure that
was never big on it
yeah I feel like the only time my dad my
dad or stepdad will get them for my mom
or my stepmom would be without like the
standard Valentine's Day birthday or
anniversary sure you know gotcha later
on I'm gonna need the name of that
gelato place
sure for sure just to check it out just
so I get a better rate it would
[__] blow your tits off it's good I
mean are we talking about like
unrecognizable flavors
would you say what do you mean like
where you have to try it wasabi or
something yeah [__] like that like is
that kind of what we're talking I mean
seven still [__] it's too many listen
I know especially for a busy night
just [__] get something [__] try
it out and come back
you know what I mean send a probe out
yeah
yeah but they're good they're real good
all right whatever Gang This is a
goddamn Family episode they're trying to
be talking about your lottery we got a
goddamn program to do but guys you know
when you sign up for the patreon we will
answer your garbage question on here uh
it's just the best way to do it we get a
lot of submissions but as always the
[__] homies get the first [__]
crack at it so let's get into it this
one's from Big O shout out to you uh
since Summer's about to be over I'm
waiting until next summer to fix my cars
AC a little jammed up I respect that
that's a that's a
see yeah you only need that for you can
kick that can down the road nine months
sure right why I mean ACS aren't cheap
either right uh it depends what it is
it's Gotta Be Like A Jihad I feel a
radiator something like that could just
be out of freon
that ain't that much yeah yeah but a lot
I mean yeah
but still
get that car detailed at least because
you've been sweating all over those
seats you're throwing an air freshener
in there you went through the whole
summer that's good thinking T-Bone spend
the money wisely yeah yeah yeah so just
do something you don't have to replace
the whole thing but make it make it make
it presentable get some of that zonos or
whatever it was called in there remember
the no-os
yeah that really hit the weed scene hard
Ozium
yeah it smells like oranges
it was all right I meant yeah at first
when I was banging this is [__] mid
90s
you had to know somebody that worked at
a [__] car wash to get it it was not
[__] on the street retail sale that
was you had to have a license you had
you had to have you had to know somebody
that worked at a car wash to get it and
it made a world of difference
better than the [__] paper towel
through the air freshener spoof
spoofing it yeah poof in it yeah I don't
think we ever had a name for it
steamrolling it or something like that
maybe we called it that would [__]
man an RA wouldn't know what to do well
it smells like oranges there was a thing
uh a friend of mine a friend of the show
found out uh we would smoke weed in his
room
and uh you could just and I would be
curious for people to try this now
because it sounds crazy you just take a
normal hit and then you know like you we
called it ghost in it you kind of hold
it till it disappears sure and then like
blow a little bit of it out you know
also known as zeroing zero it's like
yeah we can smoke in the house you just
gotta ghost it type thing and like Blow
The Remnant whatever's left out the
window you know something but they would
blow it into the his the mattress of his
bed and like the mattress would just
absorb like all the foam and stuff just
[__] that's pretty good that's not
bad why does your bed smell like Cypress
Hill yeah it's just taking rips from the
bottom it's pretty good you open the
door just hear the bubbler sound
yeah you just they would go bet it and
then like we were probably like 15 or
whatever
and it would just never come out that's
pretty good that's not bad it ain't bad
man that or a pillow I think would work
or something like that I don't think a
pillow is tight I'm sure it helps but I
don't think a pillow is tight enough you
know sure I don't know couch cushion be
perfect same thing same thing as a bed
you'll then your dad flops down what the
[__] and you got reefer ass
the hell'd you eat
walking around smelling like the dang
dang
oh you got reefer butt ooh girl you got
that reefer butt
uh
uh all right let's see here
um this one this is a cold pizza crust
ten dollar homie never had one red cold
pizza Chris is all right cpc's all right
uh is it garbage if you bring your own
red pizza delivery bag Amazon purchase
when you pick up take out food because
you live in a rural area and get sick of
your food being cold by the time you get
home man bro move I like it pro move oh
what uh what I like can we clap dude
that's [__] genius come on that's
tight that's nice we did hear something
you work here
nope that pick up for Zach Uber Eats for
Zach my thing is uh someone did mention
this before they were in ubereats or
like a seamless driver and you get a bag
because I got the bag you get like a
whole thing when I was doing the Box bag
what was I doing seamless or I think I
was doing seamless or something I was
doing doordash they send you like a
doordash hat a red t-shirt and the food
you wear that stuff no it got there late
oh God and a gun to end it all man dude
you know what somebody said someone said
for one of the patreon it was so good
for one of the patreon for one of the
next patreon goals I should have to
reopen my doordash
account and do all the deliveries with
me and him and just mic the [__] car
I will 100 do that with you we'll just
we'll just go to a town in Jersey but
wouldn't we scare people if two guys
walked up to the house no a lot of times
you just leave it and take the picture
when I was doing it one time I got to an
Uber and the lady who was supposed to be
driving was in the passenger seat and
her boyfriend was driving oh that
happens a lot attitude out of New York
that happens a lot we were in Atlanta I
got McDonald's you remember it was
these a car full of dudes smoking a
blunt rolled up and handed me my bag
that for sure had been gone through
like the sticker wasn't it was like
crumbled up at the top they were like
here you go bro I'm like [__] sweet and
sour man huh I was like I'll still eat
them nuggets
that's all right but
um the move is
you turn the oven on and he when you
heat it up get it real crispy
great it's great I don't like that you
don't like it I've never done it I don't
see the reason to do it like what is it
a pizza or you talk about anything no if
you get the pizza back and it's you it's
a little lukewarm you throw it in the
oven Crank It Up Get It Real crispy
maybe I'm not I'm not against it I just
that's not my not my vibe listen Chris
knows what he's doing yeah I'm not I'm
not going against that that guy's
splitting the garbage atom out there
that's amazing yes the forethought of
how many times do you think he [__]
sat there like man [__] I can just and
then realize I could just buy this
[__] bag remember when Domino's I
don't know if they still did it but they
had the one that would plug into the car
and keep it at like it plugged into the
Cigarette Outlet
not only did it just retain the heat it
[__] was like going through so many
ways which I respect they never stop
trying no they don't and that's I
genuinely respect Domino's fast they go
we're trying to make that we're trying
to get it to you quicker is better and
everything is possible you see what
they're doing now they have like they
can dry anywhere on the if you have the
app they'll deliver to any point they'll
come out to like the side of a [__]
intramural baseball game no kidding as
long as you can drop the point in the
map
or whatever and are they starting to
have their own cars now where it's like
a Domino's mobile where in the back they
have like almost like pizza warmers or
ovens 100 right dude I never thought
about this until now Domino's stays
Innovative dude come on they are really
dope they're the best that that tracker
wildly accurate so yeah so accurate yeah
I like knowing it's going in the oven
mm-hmm
Pizza Hut ain't doing that I don't think
so
also I have such one I love obviously
but Pizza Hut should make a hard turn
and just [__] reopen the restaurants
and just [__] give it a shot and see
what happens I don't disagree The
Nostalgia thing Nostalgia is Big
everybody's doing this so many people I
would go just for the [__] Nostalgia
of it but it'll be a lot more money you
put four in the tri-state they got it
they got cash but dude Pizza Hut's not
worried about four locations in the
tri-state try it out
give me a [__] test Market sure
there's some that are still open I know
but they don't talk about it they don't
advertise them that's how you [__]
beat dominance because let me tell you
something
then you start [__] selling now and
now everybody wants if I go to a pizza
and have it I go oh I forgot how good
this is let's order that next time if
we're on the road and you're jammed up
if you have the option can you see if
Pizza Huts are franchisees or if they're
I don't think so owned dominoes are
dominoes are probably franchises but
there's got to be something from a
business standpoint of where they all
just go as like the the takeouts you
know what I mean that's probably the
that's the money maker there's a new guy
creeping up Mel's or mics Pizza Hut is a
friend is franchises maybe that's why
they're not doing it well maybe they
weren't back in the day
they weren't franchised and they started
franchising
but you know how we feel about
franchises
killer oh you know what killer of a
corporation what was the uh
uh franchise that kept hitting me up in
your name remember it's like a
Saladworks or something like that I
started seeing them they're popping up
I'm not gonna remember what that was
a crazy Moe's or something like that
maybe
um I don't remember
but there's a new pizza like it can cost
you up to 2.1 million dollars to open up
your pizza franchise oh no it's wild and
you need to have more money
and Assets in the bank in case that
fails that they then take it's crazy see
if dominoes or sea of Pizza Hut owns any
of their stores they I'm sure they
haven't they own some of them too
like it's a corporate one
uh nothing really
listen that would be now you can't
[__] bang people over the head either
you gotta [__] you gotta keep
Teriyaki Madness yes I saw one on Route
One not too long ago yeah yeah should go
in and try it out go in you're working
there
you son of a [__] oh that's how that's
how Shaq got us at Bareburger Shaq came
in with like 30 people
sat down ordered everything literally
everything and said I'm thinking about
opening one of these [__] on the
house of course
did he end up getting into it I don't
think so ah what a scam that's what I'm
saying we're going to Teriyaki Madness
and say yeah we're I'm that guy you've
been emailing yeah yeah we're thinking
about franchising I'm a local we wanted
to come in and see what you see what you
got this is my partner HW Foley let me
go down to town open up franchise a
Teriyaki man
telling you man Pizza Hut you can't bang
people out though you got the cops you
get to crush dice I'm in I'm in the
salad bar back up
to some degree totally in pan pizza
uh uh all right let's get some people to
work what are we doing here be [__]
awesome
a Friday night that place would be
[__] mobbed you could do it in one of
the parking lots of the malls how all
the you know the Bonefish grills and the
[__] PF Changs but they did like a
big one
dude it would be [__] pack throw a
couple of [__] arcade games with me a
claw machine up front they used to start
to do the hostess which was great really
oh yeah
pictures right pictures and I think I
would always remember my dad getting a
Michelob ah was it beer with the foil
top
Chuck E cheese serves beer yeah that's
right a lot of fights happen yeah a lot
of trouble yeah there was Minnesota the
number one place for bar fights for like
three years running was some Chuck E
cheese in the middle of nowhere people
go home without kids it's walking in
cracking their Knuckles and [__] all
right let's go
ah bring it back we can get back there
we could we really could
um all right let's see this somewhere
this one's from bumping into [__]
damn that's a deep cut uh first time
cash into my 10 homie chip there you go
this is uh we were just talking about
this is a garbage hit up at Costco for
free samples on your lunch break when
you're hemmed up between checks
completely respected yes Costco it's for
the taking it's laid out there they want
you to take it that's totally fine and
that's the whole motto of the the guy
that started Costco like when they
wanted to raise the price of the hot
dogs at a pizza or whatever it was he
shut them down he said no myth real yeah
that just came out yeah damn it's what's
known in the biz is a lost leader yes
it's because not everything in Costco is
a good deal but some you can get good
deals there but not everything is but
they want you to think man we walk right
in you see that hot dog deal you go man
everything in here is a deal I'm getting
65 boxes of mac and cheese yeah okay all
right that's the same thing they do at
Walmart is they do like you're looking
at a 10 dollar toaster a 20 toaster and
a thirty dollar toaster or whatever it
is you know and you're like well I'm not
gonna get the most expensive one I'm not
a [__] Rockefeller but I don't want
this [__] ten dollar piece of [__]
I'm gonna get the 20 toaster and that 20
toaster is the same price as the 10
toaster so you're just [__] giving
them an extra 10 beans in their pocket
damn that's how they get you yeah but I
don't I still don't think Costco Minds
that no they want they will because
you're a customer you're gonna be a car
when that check clears you're coming to
Costco they want you to assume they want
you on the lot they if you're in there
they're gonna if you're in there from
every once two three days once a week
once a month they're getting their
money's worth they don't care yeah keep
because then you're walking around going
oh when my check clears [__] getting
that you know it's always chicken
patties is what they're giving away some
type of Frozen breaded chicken Love A CP
sure did I ever tell you when I was in
college my mom was it's forgotten it's
been forgotten we talked about it after
the Weaver the blue Weaver box yeah I
think we were Tyson
we were yeah we were no we were we were
a weave family
um do you remember Market Day
what
of all my school never did it but I
remember other people doing it or like
softball teams or it was like a
fundraising thing like a catalog
fundraising thing we had a bunch of [__]
like that we did Easter candy yeah and
you would get like the CR there would be
like a Christmas book and you ordered
like hey I'm gonna order four [__]
Whitman Samplers and I'm getting weird
that they had us doing that you know
what oh this is something it always gave
me a headache you know what they're
doing now what I got I just got a text
from my nephew I'm like a number seven
two nine eight four seven four yeah hey
here's a link for so and so for this
school can you donate or buy something
from the store and I'm like so if I send
a screenshot I said to my sister I'm
like is this [__] this is some sort
of scam or something she's like nah
that's legit that's what they do now
instead of like the school stores or the
fundraisers yeah
I do get that sniff them sure
um
I was uh that always gave me a headache
because I was so impressionable that
they suckered me and they would be they
would bring in an adult like some
salesman would come into an assembly
with like the short sleeve shirt and the
tie I gave you the full pitch and give
you the full pitch in talking about
candy and you'd have samples of the
candy and showing you pictures of the
candy and go get your parents to buy the
candy and Bubba you're sitting there
like I could call and it's Sue and you
know and they would do it at like seven
days period when you're starving and
you're [__] crashing from lunch you
know what I mean you're almost out the
door yeah and then you go home so you
know you're involved in a boiler room
yeah he's just got a bunch of phones in
the basement I'm doing a pumping dump
I'm like [__] and who's on a fixed
income I know could you could I get you
to the ten dollar pledge do you think
answer I mean Jesus Christ no I know
don't do it man you're all hop to both
doesn't it seem like that was [__] up
to dude like you're supposed to be
educated I guess you're teaching us how
the world Works sure hey rule number one
if you can't Mark if you can't spot the
whale in the first five minutes of the
game you're the whale
[__] you're the mark baby man what
the [__] dude dude they had us doing an
hour your God is doing this [__] out
there I've got kids kids pedaling their
[__] merch that guy was getting a cut
where'd that money go where did that
money go it's all pyramid scheme it
probably was I don't remember ever
seeing a diamond at no I think it was
like you know it goes back into the
school district I said that's the
[__] parents are goddamn Public
School were paying [__] taxes a lot
of taxes I know the [__] um who's
getting that money the superintendent
I don't know it's crazy uh when you look
back and think well we do this thing
Market day I never had it and it might
came across my mom's plate when she was
some girl she worked with her daughters
I don't know softball team a high school
was doing it the same thing like you go
through but they had frozen foods
okay right so we for a long time
this is gonna be trashy whatever it is
oh there's a frozen pizza company out of
Wilkes-Barre Pennsylvania that that I've
mentioned to you before uh I want to say
nardones or moms nardones or something
yes and this is this like you got to be
a licensed dealer or something to it I
don't know there's something but when
those things came around those things
sold themselves
there was no catalog there was no
nothing I think it was this right
yes yes yeah there was a thing
there was like I don't know it was like
an authorized dealer or you had to have
a license like the money was in the
licensing or something but those things
would come across once or twice a year
and you'd be like I'll take ten I don't
know if it was a fundraiser or just
nobody ever saw the money no I don't
know where any of the money went nobody
ever saw a [__] dime I never got a
cut
I don't know what the [__] we were
selling the pizzas for
it was nuts those things moved oh yeah
it's a couple of fat kids with zaz man
forget about it they were we were
waiting on them
Girl Scout cookies I get
um I don't like waiting on them though
you know what I mean I was gonna wait on
no I want the instant gratification I
buy them from the Bro from the girls out
to broadside by them these always you
pull up in your shopping cart I got I'm
in my go-kart
um
but yeah you get it from the kids at the
at the grocery store by the way yeah
yeah yeah that's gone in the car those
those caramel ones
Tagalongs now
we call them something different when we
were kids
they're called samoas when we were kids
samoas yeah with the coconut yeah I
don't think you're allowed to call them
that anymore which makes sense
Samoans gotcha yeah
um they call them caramel crunches or
something like that now
dude with this [__] this Market day I
was in college yeah I don't understand
so it was like it was a catalog with
frozen foods I get or they had a bunch
of stuff I never saw the catalog my mom
was trying to support this girl or
whatever
and
um
my mom goes hey I got a bunch of this
food
it was like dude they were individually
packed
[__] boneless skinless fatless
chicken breast and [__] pulled two of
them out throw them right on the George
Foreman [__] I would toast Frozen
yeah okay I would toast [__] wait
you're in college I mean I'm living at a
living like a [__] trap house okay so
there's an actual big fridge you didn't
have these in the College Board no no no
I'm not [__] no you're not we're not
allowed a George foreign
next to me sleeping with his eyes open
shout out to you flip uh I see you out
there I see you Ramon
um you take a walk in the yard dude so
it started with those and I was like
because she was like oh here's a box of
completely individual like there was no
cooking no Fest no smell no tell Scotch
you know what I mean it was easy peasy
and then the next time I came home she
goes I got you these dude they were
breaded chicken cutlets
with a brown thing of salt all Frozen I
don't know how the sauce stayed it was
like a imagine like a slice of provolone
but tomato sauce on top of that and then
a slice of provolone on top of that all
individually wrapped man I take [__]
one of those out of those packs throw
them in the microwave because you
couldn't I wasn't baking those we'd have
a baking sheet throw those in the
microwave on two [__] pieces of white
bread dude I must have ate 15
000. dude we couldn't keep them in man
uh my mama's I'd call her like a week
she'd give me a box of 40. I'd call her
a week later like yo I need to re-up
that's [__] call the plug let's go
how long did Market Day last I think she
just started going she just might I
think my mom just started calling Market
day and getting them [__] shipped to
the crib like Johnny Depp and blow you
start a flying assistant down to Mexico
I'm on a Winnebago waving
whoa
whoa we did it hey you're a good kid
here everybody gets three extra chickens
if you bought chicken plum in the 1990s
you bought it from the piece
yeah holy [__] dude I think about those
honestly every three days if I go I get
my hands on one of them right now I'd be
all right yeah throw it out in the air
fryer for [__] four minutes good
night the cheese would melt to the point
where to get like a little hard on the
plate oh I was [__] man I loved loved
me some frozen chicken boy
oh man alrighty let's see here let's do
a couple of more there
um
this one's from cougar Deb uh is it
garbage if you don't completely scrape
the price tag from the bottom of your
shoes
the [__] that's like you're getting
those what are you talking about you're
getting them at Marshalls yeah that's
where that is that's like
uh I've done it for sure and uh uh I I
have had it like three weeks later of
like you still see like 14.99 or
whatever back into a dress shoes gotta
let everybody know I don't got it I put
my feet up on every table
back in the day what was your procedure
uh how do I word this because I was I
always had anxiety of when I went in to
close shop or sneaker shop in my head
the first thing is how much are they oh
100 now did you have any hesitation of
just going in and lifting up the tongue
of the shoe and be like ah [__] this oh
you always want to look like you could
afford them if you wanted them yeah for
sure that's my my first move is looking
how much is it yeah but you can't
[__] you know you gotta go oh these
are cool you do maybe do a little flat
okay so you had that too and then
actively turn it be like oh 188 put that
back down you have anything in a
discount rack what's that a waffles
[Laughter]
I'll do a nine and a ten if that'll take
a little up
is there a cash price we can talk about
what do you got in the floor model
uh-huh yeah well you do that on sneakers
oh yeah I still do that you do you take
the floor well now you're going to bring
that box out and there's only one in
there like ah [__] you look back up at
the [__] wall there she's staring
back at you a little bit tinted from the
sunlight there was a big thing when I
was in college I want to say uh when
shoes that's like at least for me figure
like early
mid-2000s that's when shoes really
started [__]
becoming like such a thing and a lot of
these Philly a lot of places in Philly
like Super Kicks Kicks USA they were all
individually owned
but like and they would get like these
discounts it was like a
they would have like seven good Pairs
and then like 8 000 shitty pairs sure
and you would go and it'd be like a
Payless type thing of like they'd all be
there then the boxes were under the
thing and they did have like the nice
Jordans or whatever man I remember going
in I wanted a pair of white Converses so
bad in the summer and it was like you
know they were 50 bucks I didn't have it
or I probably had like 70 in my account
I was like I can't spend you know get
some slightly yellow ones dude and there
was mustard on this on like the floor
model like actual like a fingerprint
like somebody
probably eating a soft pretzel and put a
fingerprint of mustard on it and I was
so close to buying it my friend was like
dude
could you have gotten it off no it was
in there okay and he was also like I'm
not gonna let you live this down like
the second you wear those to a party I'm
calling you out immediately I was like
all right fair enough
they get to not buy shoes that day yeah
we had Sneaker King back in the day
Sneaker King was all right sounds all
right it was great we used to have it
smelled like you were in one giant brand
new sneak like when you walked in there
like that love that uh we had Phil's
shoes that was like the one we went to
in our town local
Phil worked there his son worked there
it was good you felt good my mom I'll
take you to Phil's you get one pair and
I think that's where the kids would get
their the kids my brother and sister
would get their Catholic school shoes
like you had to get like Phil was an
authorized dealer or whatever so we
always went there and then I remember
when they closed when they closed and
the epic video next to them closed I was
like man times are [__] changing I'm
moving into the corporate takeover when
we lived in South Philly I always uh
wished
I was around on Passyunk Avenue where
like that jeans place was big oh not big
Marty's uh jeans World jeans something
denim world yeah when those were popping
I bet you those places were [__]
awesome so I've been remembering that
[__] I've been in some of them yeah so
it's so weird you bring that out because
I thought of the stories I was telling
that uh uh Pat his family's from down is
all from South Philly so that's where
they would grow I went with Pat Pat and
his dad and uh it must have been all
right he had to stop and get [__]
clothes like pants Pat did like in his
dad's like we're down here this is where
we're going and it was like [__] you
know Gigolos jeans or whatever it was
real thoughts actually shout out to Big
Gay to my boy big gay in this is Dad's
place Gigolos down there on Patrick
clothing store yeah it's called jingles
see if you can find Gigolos on fat young
Avenue
my buddy big Ann welcome to adulterers
everybody
you like what you see
closed
yeah I think he sold it a couple years
old but we were in college adulterers do
you like what you see it's pretty
goddamn good do you likely
adulterers don't tell nobody yeah
um
and he went there and I remember walking
in there dude it was like
straight out of the [__] 70s straight
out you walked in it was like an old
woman I got it was like [__] out a
good Fellas lady named Ruth yeah it was
all right yeah uh all right let's see
here let's do one more and then we gotta
wrap her up there gang
um this one is from medicinal Crocs and
compression socks shout out to the big
man sure is it garbage if your sole
purpose of working out is to hit more
dingers and slow pitch softball no
that's all right I respect that more
than going I don't know I'm just a big
juice head like a big Meathead
putting up numbers you know what I mean
you're working towards something there
are a few things in life that feel as
good as really connecting with one it's
just I never have connect them with a
home run I don't know I never hit a home
run in your life we never I never really
played baseball you did a home run in
Little League maybe one or two all right
so don't act like you're [__] married
I didn't say that I didn't say that uh I
put a couple deep though I'll tell you
that I know but the way you responded
it's like you you when you did 71
seasons
collapse
that's a good documentary you've never
hit a home run I don't know wiffle ball
I mean Wiffle ball you're not that's not
a true home run and whistle there it is
hard way harder to hit than assault yeah
well you're not playing on it did you
run around the bases that's a home run
yeah other than that yeah but I didn't
play I [__] hated baseball I didn't
play baseball really I told maybe I was
six
hmm and I didn't have the upper body
strength then had the [__] torso I
could turn the hips tear my fat little
ass little shorby oh but no I didn't I
didn't play
I don't think I played past like kid
pitch one year okay yeah maybe one or
two
in Little League where it was like
proper over the fence [__] Gary bonds
over here
kick rocks
so I respect the move I do too also you
know it gives you something if that's
what motivates you to get into shape
sure and be healthy cracking dingers and
for the love of God stretch before the
game the amount of blown out ankles and
knees that come out of like adult
softball homes
all right my brother she's like I'm
playing soccer and do men's league I'm
like first of all this is gonna happen
what when
like now yeah that's crazy oh door is
ACL oh you did yeah of course he did
okay this is gonna end horribly no no no
no I'm gonna bet you if my life
MCL right he had to have surgery really
yeah I didn't know that uh-huh it's a
bummer and then another guy got knocked
out
I'm like dude that sounds
yapping I was just like yeah yeah you're
too old to be doing it you got to take
care of yourself dude softball's a
little different softball's different
it's not a high impact you're not doing
that much running you're drunk oh man in
Chicago in the summer around 3 P.M every
single bar is full of dudes who look
like they just got jumped
all covered all cover dirt and stuff
going to Hokage bar with your [__] uh
softball uniform on we were talking to
[__] DeRosa about starting a joey
Rose's team
I would love that that would be fun who
would he play like they do have that
Showbiz League they do like it's like a
proper Showbiz League yeah I know people
in it oh they play for like Broadway
plays yeah
like like they have in [__] Seinfeld
those guys up what are you talking about
they have in Seinfeld really yeah
couple of singers and dancers can they
play probably I can't but
they're doing pirouettes around the
bases yeah you're built more for like
kicking dirt on an umpire's feet I can
manage you can manage I don't know I
don't know nothing about baseball though
you'd be a good first base coach if you
can sit on a stool that could stand I'm
gonna wait I'd want Third Base because
I'd want to [__] it I bet you do
what the hell Third Base finger popping
I don't know
I'd want to be able to wave people home
and I'd be real loose with it too you
got it
keep going that's got to be the best
feeling as a third mate goes [__]
send them home I was telling you to go
uh we gotta wrap it up
gang I'm gonna tell you this right now
and I mean it from the bottom of my
heart we absolutely love you yeah and
we'll see you next week